yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
once I was
you know
[Music]
many times
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Laughter]
come on
[Music]
in me
from me
[Music]
and welcome back to the realest podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims today we
are here with one of our OG guests Abu
American Sonic and brother how you doing
you say OG yes man I remember when you
guys were first getting started off man
I was talking uh talking to you Brothers
man that's a beautiful thing to see you
Brothers blow up like this man it's just
supporting us in the beginning and
everything you know absolutely I
wouldn't have it any other way man but
it's been killing it since
so before we get started with
um today's actual topic did you guys see
the debate between royal tomasi fresh
and fit Destiny and sneako I saw I saw
clips of it I didn't see the whole thing
I saw Clips oh okay okay so what was
your first impression of those clips I
mean you know I'm think everybody knows
that I know Rolo roll adventure mean is
third book
um fourth book or third book you know he
he talks to me back and forth quite a
bit about it and um so I guess I
consider him in the sense as close as
you can be with a non-muslim as a friend
however that works then he would be
considered one but I have to say I
completely disagreed with him on a
statement about like vasectomies and
whatnot and uh it's just really I found
that like
a bit strange you know of a statement so
that a lot of people would take
exception to it without question in my
mind it makes perfect sense that a lot
of people would like you know give them
smoke for that yeah so do you think this
is something that Rolo would have said
like a year or two ago maybe in the
beginning
who's going to be a controversial
statement now because I you know like I
said I do consider him to be a friend
although I have kind of in my just just
to be clear to any viewers I don't
really consider myself red pill I did
learn some red pill you know what not I
spent a lot of time in that zone but I
do consider myself as a person who's
exited it
um because of what I call Red Pill rot
and in my humble estimation this is
where the the dodgy part comes in
um where you know he might take offense
I hope he doesn't but I consider this
could be red pill right I mean I coined
the phrase red pill Rock and red pill
rot is basically when someone spends so
much time in red pill and red pill
ideology
um that it just starts to really change
the way you perceive the world and
relationships and women
for the negative and that's why I call
it rot because it degrades instead of
builds you know the ideas I got just
allow me to rant for a second guys sorry
I got into red pill because I was
looking for help with my marriages you
know I I was married for 26 years I
ended up in a divorce and I wanted to
get married again and I want to get
married to multiple women I couldn't
find help I turned to Red Pill
and that's what I went there for I went
there to look for help but after a while
I noticed like okay they're starting to
be negative attributes in myself because
I'm very self-aware of my behaviors and
my manners you know and so I caught that
then I started observing others and I
was like okay this is not unique to me
because I was thinking maybe it's a
problem of me and so this is where I
came with red pill rotten it took years
to actually observe so you know
yeah I think that's a that's a red pill
right thing because a year ago he wasn't
saying things like this now he's saying
something like telling a 20 year old you
know get a vasectomy that's
I find that problematic outlandish yeah
considering how doctors I don't know if
this is correct
um but my understanding is doctors tell
you that you should consider a vasectomy
to be permanent that's the consideration
they tell you when you're supposed to
get it this is what I was this is my
understanding so you're gonna tell a guy
in his early 20s to get a vasectomy
yeah
yeah it is crazy yeah I honestly
honestly at this point I would relate
red pill kind of like to nihilism in a
way because like nihilism is is on the
fundamental level you're setting
yourself up to be depressed and have a
like just a really sad outlook on life
with red pulse the same thing and you
could see it in the the debate like I I
reacted the whole thing live like for an
hour two hours straight and you could
see like with the some of the things
mine was saying it's very like
disturbing for a man he was saying that
as a man you have no value until you
build it so a man who's not famous and
rich is just not valuable at all he's
just worthless like that's a very
depressing thing to think that's like
that's like thinking you know there's no
point in life there's no purpose I have
no reason for being here I'm just gonna
be here and die and everything's useless
like it's very depressing to be honest
so it's horrible and you know I'm right
now on my channel and when I have time
um we were just talking about this a
little while ago I don't have a lot of
time I mean we're talking about this for
my time but I read from the book uh the
evil Cravings of wealth and status you
know uh and I read that and I upload
that to the channel it's a very good
book even Roger
um and um it's just when we look at from
an Islamic principle what what
constitutes high value
you know what I mean what what have they
caught what if they said is high value
in today's term it's like money game
money make what is what is it uh mod
says I don't have principally I don't
have a problem with it but it's along
those lines money muscle something and
game or something like this and there's
more to it than this yes you know than
than just um chasing the Dunya really uh
and that's the yeah if you're gonna
chase the Junior you're always going to
be behind
I can't remember who said it was one of
the great Scholars of the past he said
the Dunya is like a bride
you know that's like a bell bride who
like you know never marries you you're
always chasing her but she never like
marries you you didn't spend your life
you know pretty yeah in a realistic
State absolutely yeah the prophet
there's actually Hadith where he said
that there are two Realms or two things
that anyone who chases it will never be
satisfied one is the the one who seeks
knowledge and the other one is the one
who seeks the Dunya they're never going
to be satisfied it's like an ocean that
you that you know you leave one Shore
and then there's no there's no end of it
on the other side yeah
and I understand that appeal because
I've been there
but it's like
how what's a good explanation of this
red pill for a Muslim
is like a double-edged sword
you need the sword but unfortunately the
handle is also double edged and bladed
does that sound right so you've got a
sword and then the handle is also a
sword yeah
yeah
you know what I mean I yeah so I'm I you
know this is for Muslims if you're not
Muslims you know you can the Dunya is
anything goes you know but um for
Muslims it's really it's really a realm
that they shouldn't be delving in
um
in my humble estimation yeah and let's
let's talk a little bit as to why sorry
I don't know if you want to jump in bro
no no I was gonna ask one but please if
we can continue
let's jump in let's jump into why why is
red pill bad why is it wrong
okay
wrong in a sense this is difficult
because I'm I'm not gonna say it's wrong
but I'm not gonna advise Brothers to get
into it just because that's not wrong
like I said it's a double-edged sword
and the blade the handle is also bladed
you know so but the problematic on
multiple levels
you know first off what we have to do is
we have to look at like where it started
and why it started where and why it
started was mostly because the
non-muslim guys were having problems
with their women right
and why were they having problems
because these people have left their
religion I mean when they were and
in the sense of like
we're speaking in a general sense a
religious Society is better than a
non-religious one you know
um
I'm not it's not a comparative to Islam
of course but I would rather live in a
practicing Christian Society than a than
a than a not practicing Western society
as we see right now with all this stuff
going on with children and these other
types of things with deciding what
gender you're going to be we see what
happens when you remove the religion
from a state and a nation and a people
they become worse and so when they when
this started to happen they look for
answers so red pill was reactionary to
feminism and the sexual Revolution
already off the bat you're wrong because
now you're turning to like man-made uh
uh uh systems in order to correct what a
man-made system and ideas which are
faulted right off the bat Muslims we
have a system all you have to do is
follow the book in the Sunnah everybody
men and women and our problems will be
rectified but this is also a problem
with us unfortunately as Muslims is that
you know we're looking for answers in
places that
well we don't need to look for them so
it's like
if we just stick to the book in the
Sunnah first and foremost red pill is
not needed now obviously we have
um feminism and whatnot and all these
other movements coming around and
everybody's like absorbing stuff left
and right because we live in Western
society and whether we like to admit it
or not we do absorb a percentage of the
culture of the people that we live with
and so in turn Muslims started to see
like oh well I see sisters doing this
because you know red pill and whatnot
you know we were looking for answers and
it's like oh sisters are doing this yeah
that comes from this and then we could
start to correlate behaviors between
Muslims and non-muslims because again
we're absorbing the culture around us
instead of like you know sticking you
know just holding on with our molar
teeth to the book in the Sunnah
and so we started to also find answers
but then with finding answers it's the
same problem because it's reactionary
you're pulling in problems you see what
I mean
because when we look at feminism we see
that the the outcome has been negative
right and everybody both the non-muslims
and the Muslims the Muslims follow the
non-muslims in this following hand span
per hand span as we know is the Hadith
test
we see the the negative outcomes of
feminism what we haven't seen so far or
what we're starting to see now are the
negative outcomes of red pill
because this is newly this is a newly
introduced concept right
we've had we've had a long time 70 plus
years of feminism if not more if we look
at the suffragettes
um and we've seen the outcomes of it so
now we start doing the same thing with
red pill we're just throwing like hey
Concepts and ideas out there we're not
really sure what the results are but we
do now now we see well I call it red
pill Rock we start seeing nilism
creeping because especially from the
non-muslim perspective these guys got
into it to learn about women they
learned about women it worked but what
happened then they started seeing only
negative about women and thinking only
negative about women because what they
wanted they got what they say be careful
what you wish for so they started
sleeping with women because that's that
was the primary goal of them of theirs
with red pill and then they're like well
women can't be loyal because I'm going
out here using what I learned to sleep
with people's wives and therefore if I
get married that's going to happen to my
wife why would this happen to a Muslim
if we're sticking to the book in the
center we're following our religion
what do we do we we keep it in our pants
right it's easy to chase the Dunya but
we don't we resist PCB law and so it's
just from the from the ground up there's
a lot of problems for a Muslim when he
starts looking at red pill it's just
chock full of it and I nobody's been
there longer than me I you find me a
Muslim that's been there longer than me
nobody can tell me I'm wrong
yeah I've had brothers from University
Brothers when I say Brothers I'm talking
about us Brothers Muslim Brothers he
said yeah I learned red pill
and you know because I got rejected by a
sister I really wanted I really wanted
to marry the sister this is a true story
brother told me this and may Allah I
hope Allah rectified is fair I don't
know what happened when we stopped
talking a long time ago I'd advise him
with the fear of Allah he's like and
then I was so mad that I just started
sleeping with sisters all over the
university he said to the point that I
slept with over 20 sisters on the
University campus
he says just out of anger he wasn't even
he was just mad he just wanted to
basically like one of those people that
just like destroyed the world you know
he wants to watch the world burn
and this really I think that was the
point when I was like I was already on
the idea of retro Rock and then right
there I was just like you know what this
is like this is super problematic and
that's the day that I decided I was like
you know I wasn't going to teach game I
was going to teach like you know uh
anything else about red pill and I
started like really moving away from it
yeah yeah that's good to hear
before I get into what I wanted to say
on her bro I want to hear your thoughts
on this
I was gonna add on to it that it's the
problem is now that a lot of Muslims
will say oh well why don't we just take
from it what works like take the good
stuff and then leave the best of but
then it's like you said if we're on the
Quran and we're on the summer if we're
actually looking into this
I mean this gives you everything that's
the good things that you will find in
RedTube
I mean yeah I used to I used to say that
I would say it's like cooking you know I
used to say red pill is like cooking you
know the comparison is cooking it's like
you know if you have a hamburger we can
one for one make a hamburger it's a
Muslim because we can use
beef chicken whatever else bacon Burgers
we can still copy because we have beef
bacon turkey bacon there's chicken bacon
no there's not chicken bacon but there's
turkey and beef bacon so we can make you
know bacon Burgers but if you want a
pork chop there's no way you can like
you can't replace the pork out of a pork
chop sandwich it's pork chop therefore
we abandon it and that was my ideal a
red pill at the time but it's just
you know there's channels out there and
you know I love all my brothers out
there but we see it it no matter how you
deal with red pill it ends up
adversarial
because the reality is there is a
reality there and this comes into the
part where we talk about realities uh
but it's also problematic men and women
do have different reproductive
strategies and automatically when you
push yours you're going to put yourself
in conflict with the woman but it's not
necessary because the book in the center
covers all this already
right it tells us how to deal with our
relationships from polygyny to monogamy
or whatever else so really what do we
need we need to go back to
vetting our partners you know properly
making sure that they're upon the
religion so that they act upon a
religion so when you marry somebody you
don't have these problems
yeah and look where the problem really
lies
we as Muslims
we're going to non-muslims
to try to solve our problems
it's like we don't we didn't reflect and
see that these non-muslims as well but
how are they going to know the truth
how they're going to know anything
they're over here working on like they
don't have that objective truth they
don't have these this instruction manual
these guidelines that they're working
off of so they're just going with
whatever they find and they're finding
this stuff that's a red pill so you're
gonna go to these people and you're
gonna try to get the answers for
something that you're going to in your
life when in reality maybe you should be
looking at the proper Muslim men
and who maybe they've taken care of this
issue because it's a rise in their life
maybe if if you were to find these men
and you would have asked them and take
advice from them then you would actually
solve the problem that you're trying to
solve in a much better light than going
to someone who uh just has no real
direction for like a better words you
know um and it's funny because
we've we've had about like
[Music]
seven to ten years of red pill right now
that I've like that I've been looking at
and I can't name personally anyone who's
entered into the Zone found what they
were looking for and like properly
exited it I mean everybody's still doing
the same thing same problems same
discussions over and over and over
if it worked so well why are there still
so many problems
nice you see what I mean
for me I came in I I found what I was
looking for I'm not advising you guys to
do this I found what I was looking for I
found problems also and I left
and then everybody's like well I'm
American you disappeared offline well
yeah I got the life I want but mostly
where did it come from it came from the
book on the sun it didn't come from like
red pill you know
but 99 of it there's a few things that
you know you could say oh uh
get money get fit whatever else but
that's just general information anyway
you want why would you not want to be in
the best version of yourself that you
want to be anyway that does not like
exclusively red pill you know I mean
even even that you'll find traces of it
in Islam you know the strong believer is
better and more loved by Allah than a
weak believer but there's you know
everyone and this is the thing I mean
for like anyone who practices or
believes in red pill name one thing
that's good in red pill that we don't
have in Islam already
I promise you anything you can name is
already directly mentioned
they look up to us well that's why so
many people have become Muslim
that's why so many people have become
Muslim just coming into the scene I mean
we know I think your brothers just did
recently yeah I wish I had time to like
watch a lot of content but you better
just did recently did a rude streak
though he came with some right
look at that group around and I've seen
a clear change in his mentality in his
way of thinking since he's been you know
we've got all these brothers all these
people who have accepted Islam
alhamdulillah you know even me
like 11 12 people accepted Islam through
the Abu American Channel and I've never
been about like Dao because I hold it
that specifically something that you
need to be at least qualified for or
have like you know been being studied
which is the religion and I felt like
you know that's not that wasn't that was
outside the scope of what I did
and people accepted to stop because why
because the answers are there
yeah
but you don't see them you know where do
we see this in red pill like I said we
still got guys still talking about the
problems that are happening today if it
works so well why are the women still
not responding the way you want them to
yeah that's a good point imagine if
there was I imagine if there was as many
good practicing Muslim men as there were
red pill men you know online and all
that stuff and we would actually this is
the thing we would really make an impact
I remember Myron and not the debate but
in the discussion he had on his podcast
with sneaker before
um he was saying like feminism's here to
stay it's not going anywhere I'm like
what is this like defeatist mentality
bro Islam is here and Islam is going to
stay in Islam is going to dominate this
is the mentality we need to have as men
you know especially him because he's he
is the Muslim uh at least you know he he
says he's the Muslim opening
alhamdulillah so we take his word for it
and may Allah bless him and guide him
and uh and his co-host as well you know
this is a mentality Muslims need to have
and it's crazy because people people for
some reason don't want to see as it as
like you know red pill versus Islam but
I agree with what you said it is a
religion I mean think about it they have
their Credo beliefs you know hypergamy
or what a high value man is the goal
they have the entire goal which is to be
with women they have their book all the
Royal tomasi book 38 Laws of Power and
that stuff
um I know he didn't write that one but
yeah that's one of them they have their
Prophet Rolo tomasi they have their
their Dias you know people like
um I don't want to name any names and
kind of you know throw people out there
but you know they have the you can think
of a red pill person online that's
that's promoting Red Bull they have
everything they have the Apologetics and
everything
yeah
indeed absolutely
so yeah I I don't know you know
I understand the appeal
um but guys just stay out of it it will
it will mess you up on one way or
another you know alhamdulillah I'm
happily married you know it's multiple
women you know um I consider my my
family life to be you know happy and
stable
um
but I can't say that it hasn't left my
you know impacting damage on myself you
know the only issue is like I said I'm
very self-aware of my behavior so when
I'm acting crazy online I know I'm
acting crazy online guys so when I'm at
home I also know when I'm like when I'm
displaying negative attributes and so I
think to myself like okay where did this
come from and why and I can I can
literally 100 trace it back to red pill
and this is something that you know in
general you need to be anyway self-aware
of like your you know what causes you to
act and behave in certain ways and what
triggers you but um I'm telling you you
spend time in that zone guys you're
gonna pick up a whole lot of different
triggers that are not that you don't
have to we all have baggage as human
beings don't don't go around like just
picking up more just for the sake of
picking it up you're carrying whatever
your parents put you with you know and
all this type of other stuff you got
bullied in school or whatever
you went through in life and then you
want to go into a zone of a bunch of
guys generally what I call and let me
just go ahead and throw this in here
because you guys know I love my rants
vasopressin suppressed individuals
trying to tell you how to have a
relationship if you don't know what
that's the person is women have oxytocin
men have vasopressin this is the bonding
chemical that your body excretes when
you're in a relationship
now what happens when you have too much
let's just boil it down to dopamine
let's just boil down a dopamine you know
you get high you get dopamine you get
excited dopamine right and then if you
have downright if you have too much
Dopey dopamine in your body what happens
is it's called down regulation receptor
transcription meaning you need more of
that thing
in order to get that old high back
these guys who are teaching you red pill
they're out here sleeping with tons and
tons of women well what are they good at
they're good at sleeping with tons and
tons of women I mean if it's fat
suppressing
he's experienced down regulation
receptor transcription and vasopressin
what's he going to teach you about a
relationship
nothing because
because and what do Muslims want we want
families we want children and this guy
he can't teach you that I it's not a
joke there's guys from the red pill
scene I'm not going to crap on them some
of my my friends as much as they can be
as Muslims non-muslims
they contact me for help on how to keep
the women that they get
and you'd be surprised with some of
their names
so
what are you learning
did I'm telling you they can't teach you
they can't teach you you okay maybe
they'll teach you how to get a girl you
can't keep her now what are you gonna do
you're gonna end up like me like apple
America with like 14 divorces no
don't
you think I wanted to end up like that I
didn't
I came from a stable two-parent
household that lasted for a long time no
my parents separated now but they act
long after we left the house long when
we grew up you know
you don't want to end up like that guys
I'm telling you because every time it
happens it hurts it hurts and that's
something they don't tell you also they
run around they act Alpha whatever else
the going term is and there are a bunch
of guys out there that are hurt because
there's always you're always going to
meet that girl and you're gonna be like
wow she's amazing and then when it
doesn't work the way you want it to
you're gonna get hurt and it's just it's
all you're going to do is you're gonna
get married to some sister and you're
gonna hurt her and it's gonna cause a
chain reaction a BS for a whole bunch of
people because then she's gonna go hurt
somebody you're gonna go out and
probably screw it up again
how many single mothers do we see in the
ummah how many divorce Brothers do we
need more stay away from that stuff guys
well why you stay away from me
I heard people hurt people rant over
sorry
you're right man you're absolutely right
heard people hurt people it's
unfortunate it creates a creates a very
flat approach you know it's like it's
like how we said you know someone goes
to this person and they're trying to
figure out oh like how do I uh keep this
woman that I'm with it's like oh this
person doesn't even know how to keep the
woman so what they're going to tell you
is from their own hurt perspective their
own flawed perspective so that means
that the advice you're getting is going
to lead you to the same results that
this person got themselves you know
before I became Muslim when I stumbled
onto the Roto it was all about
uh the whole woman thing right female
nature all this stuff it was actually
following the split between me and the
woman that I was with again before Islam
and I wanted to understand like what
happened why was it that this occurred
how can I stop this from happening how
can I keep women how can I have multiple
women all this stuff
and I remember watching these people and
you know there's no reason to even say
the names it's I'm not trying to put
anyone down because we're all kind of
learning as we go but these people what
they were spitting at first it seemed
like gems at first I was like oh wow
like this is it like I've been missing
out on this this is the truth and the
more I went on it I I experienced
exactly what you said bro it's the Rock
The Red Pill rock where I I started to
feel very bitter towards women I'm still
here trying to like get women trying to
do all this stuff yeah I'm very bitter
and I'm over here saying that uh every
woman is uh
I mean I don't know if I can say this
here on the stream but you know exactly
what I'm talking about bro I I would I
would even go as far as to say that my
own mom and my own grandma and my own
sister with this now Allah forgive me
bro may Allah forgive me but this is the
kind of mentality that this was putting
in my head and it wasn't until I let go
of red pill that everything that I was
trying to look for before repeal
actually revealed this stuff to me
yeah
yeah it has
I think it causes more
this is I'm trying to let me
focalize my let me Focus my thoughts
here it causes a lot of damage in the
sense that I'll just I like to speak for
myself so let me speak from myself and
then I can give examples from others
that I've seen
like I said it helped me get what I
wanted I got like the women I wanted
they were beautiful amazing whatever
else but then why couldn't I keep them
you know and then it puts you again like
you said in this spiral and because
people are ego driven creatures most
people don't really see the fault of
their own
in what happens you know and this is
this is actually how I wrote the vetting
guide when I wrote it you know because I
was like okay
what am I doing wrong because when I
when I came into this whole scene over
10 years ago of red pill and everything
I was like what am I doing wrong that I
can't stay married you know or I can't
meet a woman or whatever else and then
when I actually figured it out I started
getting the women and things still
weren't working I was like okay I
followed the steps the steps worked what
happens now why am I still having
negative results so I started looking at
myself you know and then when you start
putting the the puzzle pieces together
you start looking at others you start
listening to others like okay this isn't
gonna work and when you look at the
non-muslims it's not working
fresh and pick can have that show every
single week what's changed he can do
that show every week for the next 20
years you think it's Gonna Change it's
not going to change it doesn't fix
anything Islam has always been slightly
Affairs of the people always we have not
seen this from red pill and I've been in
red pill scene over 10 years now yeah
yeah I think that's beautifully sad and
just to add to that point I think the to
point out the exact issue is it's that
it's a reaction right like if you're
always reacting to what someone else
likes let's say you're in a fight you're
always reacting to what they're doing
you're never gonna throw anything you're
not going to win that fight eventually
you're going to lose because you're just
reacting red pill is a reaction to
feminism and it's really kind of
highlighted with the way they speak
about it's like okay this is how
you know you you get women the whole
thing is focused on women you know watch
out for these extreme type of women
that's a reaction you know only go for
the women that will XYZ
again a reaction they are
I think so broken
and defeated that
they have made their goal just sleeping
around and I think for a lot of guys if
they realize that these men their entire
goal in life is to sleep with random
women
they will instantly be turned off and be
like that's kind of sad and and it's
kind of a bait and switch if you think
about it red pill is the biggest bait
and switch that I've seen in recent
history because you get in and they're
like work out make lots of money be a
good man you know build your Brotherhood
and you're like I love that I need that
as a man we all need that as on yeah
let's let's do it and then it's some at
some point switches and it's like so you
can get all these women now
you're a kind of black pilled and now
you're a MIG tower now like you're just
in some weird extreme or you just feel
raged because you're you're just very
angry at women because they've been
reduced in your mind to the this this
insane sick gold digging creature that
will just you know eat whatever from
anyone
and then end up with the the man with
the most money or something like that
it's very very sad and depressing
you know and that's the problem at its
core being reactionary instead of like
you know focusing on the book and the
Sunnah you know if a lot of guys would
just like like and this is not a sales
pitch but if guys would just focused on
betting period don't don't use Abu
Americans vetting system use your own
vetting system which would be the book
in the Sunnah if you stick to the
vetting system of the book of the Sunnah
which is married woman religion
so you're not gonna have any problems
with feminists brothers or the artist
sisters feminist that was feminists
whatever else okay you're exclusionary
Zone doesn't have to involve a whole
bunch of red pill or whatever else
exclude women who are just like not the
ones that meet the standard that we want
as Muslim men period tell us all your
problems are solved you don't need to go
external you know I I understand the
appeal because there's a lot of women
out there that are like chasing or they
don't even realize they're affected by
feminism but then again that makes your
job easier
and if you feel like whatever else if
you want to have a negative feeling and
say hey you know what I don't I don't
think in the west I can find what I want
to go back home or go somewhere else in
another country I don't have a single
Western wife it's not because I hate
Western women it's just the attributes
I'm looking for are from women that are
not from the West unfortunately there's
always a solution you know 100 yeah
sorry no no worries bro I was just gonna
add on to that point and say also
obviously we don't want to overestimate
our own influence and be like oh yeah I
can change her but at the same time
don't completely underestimate your
influence and say you know you know I
can maybe I can't help it maybe maybe
there's room there and I I found out
with a lot of brothers and sisters you
know it happens I think more so with
brothers that they they're like when I'm
older I'm going to have multiple wives
and my women are all going to submit to
me because they're the women I'm the man
and all this stuff and then they
actually enter a relationship and
realize this is a human being it's a lot
deeper than just oh she's a woman she's
going to submit you're the man you're on
top you know there's a lot of
intricacies you have to be passionate
and merciful and loving and and all this
stuff because being a leader doesn't
mean that you you Smackdown and hammer
on people's head it means that you lead
properly with love and compassion and
you make sure that you're doing
everything you can for their benefit and
progress and the benefit and progress of
the entire team that you're leading
right and when a man gets to that point
he usually switches back on a few of the
things that he's he said in the last
year or two and I think it's the same
with sisters you know they get married
they realize
that there's a lot more to men than you
know what they've been told or what
they've been taught they just need the
right man yeah absolutely I agree I mean
this is also true I mean if a guy is
doing what he's supposed to be doing and
I mean we're just talking in general
like I said a lot of this stuff that
they're they're preaching it's
disconnected from Red Pill like I said
you know why would you not go to the gym
you just why not just be the best most
fit version of yourself that you can be
you know it's gonna make it easier to do
your Hodge it's going to make it easier
to do your Salah in old age you know if
you build your body now that's nothing
that's not connected red pill and women
like that you know so being the best
version of yourself in general
disconnected from external ideologies
you know it's going to help you
absolutely without question you know um
there are there is more to men and women
have learned some some some uh very
interestingly uh incorrect information
on men I don't know how to rectify that
you know as a guy but um
yeah we have dancers in Islam all we
have to do is look to it and like you
said and the reality is you're
absolutely right you have to be a
vanilla I mean just some general advice
you know advice to guys out here from a
guy who's probably done everything wrong
that you can do in a relationship and I
can tell you right now as a guy who's
come to a lot happily married now uh is
benevolent dictatorship I guess is what
um is what you need where it's like you
know you are a dictator but at the same
time it's like your people are your
people and you love your people and so
you do the best for your people you know
but at the end of the day the
responsibility and accountability is
yours and women do want you to lead that
doesn't take red pill to tell you that
you know women always wanted leaders
that was known before red pill popped up
and they put it under the red pill idea
or the red pill concept these are basic
simple things that we see in Islam you
know but you have to study the zero you
have to study you know Islam to see
these examples and the biggest problem I
think that we have in today's time is
the ability to extrapolate this from the
Sierra and from the Hadith I think this
is a big problem where it's like the
ability to extract that information and
say ah here's an example
you know yeah but that's beautifully
said actually it reminded me of
something I read in in this book called
The the Creed of Imam and by healthy
this is on the the chapter of you know
obedience to the to the rulers and uh
kind of those in authority
and
I'm trying to find the exact Hadith
because it mentions the you know the
husband so on and so forth so maybe one
of you can jump until I can find it so
I'm not wasting time
yeah I'm just looking at some of the
comments here
yeah
brother's going off on your comment
section mashallah in a good way or a bad
way
ah there's a lot going on here
maybe they don't like the the dictator
term
yeah that's not being a dictator that's
just being a leader
um I mean the dictator is a leader you
know
which one I use dictator is because the
the reason why I say dictator
um it has negative connotations but at
the same time it's it's it doesn't have
to be negative we've turned it negative
because of again Western socialization
but if we look from a literal term from
if we go all the way back to
um
it's a dictatorship they decide what is
final period there's no argument on it
there's no discussion and he makes
decisions for the best of his people
you dictate to your people what is going
to be and what is not going to be it's
not a negative thing I mean look at look
at democracy
how's that working out you know you got
a bunch of people who might not be so
smart voting on who's going to be the
smartest and the leader and then we see
with Western leaders how things are
going it's not going very well yeah I
think I think just the term dictator has
a really bad connotation like look at
the movies a dictator people think of
like
um Kim Kim Jong-un whatever his name is
people think of you know these horrible
people who just will like cut off at
like three generations of your family if
you like you know look at them the wrong
ideas yeah
yeah 100 100 I actually I just found the
Hadith who was in the chapter earlier
and the messenger of Allah he said and
this is
indeed each of you is a shepherd and
each of you is responsible for his flock
so he already paints a picture of Like a
Shepherd leading you know his flock of
sheep or whatever
the ruler who is over people is a
shepherd and responsible for them this
is like the Khalifa This is the leader
of the the entire nation
the husband is a Shepherd over his
household and responsible for him so
just like the ruler is The Shepherd of
the entire nation the father is a
shepherd of his his entire household he
has to lead them you know as if he's a
Shepherd leading his flock is sheep a
man's wife is a Shepherd over her
husband's home and her children or their
children and she is responsible for them
a man's slave is a Shepherd over his
master's property and responsible for it
each of you is a shepherd and each of
you is responsible for his own flock
this is why Islam is so beautiful
accountability
when you are not in charge right like
for example let's think of the the man
outside of this context of his house
he's not the leader the Khalifa is a
leader so he must obey he must be a
follower in that case and obey the
leadership absolutely when he's in his
house he has the responsibility what
some men don't like it to be honest they
want to be lazy and not have to leave
their house I was working all day and
you know some lazy men are like that
you get there you actually have the
responsibility you know yes the right
but also the responsibility you have to
leave now you have to take care of your
family you have that responsibility
there and the wife and the kids have to
listen when the father is out it's the
wife's responsibility the kids have to
listen and so on and so forth so that's
the beauty of Islam accountability red
pills like you know make money and be
with XYZ and then you can kind of screw
off till you die
yeah and a lot of times
um what I'm seeing also recently is like
a lot of these guys they're they're
living lives that are not congruent with
their message
you know yeah
um so you'll have like some guys out
here they're they're preaching this
ideas these these Concepts and it's like
then then there'll be some you know
expose on their entire life and it's
like whoa bro you live like that you
know it's like what happened to a whole
red pill thing man what are you doing
here homie
so uh I'm seeing a lot of that too you
know uh and so yeah it's really just um
[Music]
if it worked so well why is there so
many contradictions and conflicts you
know yeah I don't know this goes into
the thing like single mothers let's talk
about that real quick red pill like they
really you know in retro World they
really Rail and rally against single
mothers you know and fair every
individual is allowed to have their
preference you don't want to marry
single mother don't marry single mother
that's your preference knock knock
yourself out you know what I mean some
people are not going to want to marry
black people some people not going to
want to marry people some people not
gonna marry whatever you're allowed to
have your preferences knock yourself out
with it but what we don't do in Islam
and what we've never seen from the book
in the Sunnah and which is why I don't
do it is we don't see anybody just
taking dumps on single mothers whether
widowed or divorced we don't see it
islamically anywhere
you know so it's like why would you as a
Muslim now start
rallying and you know and railing uh
against a brother who decides to do that
it's his choice let him have it call us
why you why are you getting into this
this is not your business he took it he
made a decision he understood he
calculated it maybe he didn't
who cares
you got married
oh
that's why you got to get all into his
you know red pill like ah but you
married single mother you're cooked out
you're this that you're whatever you're
blah blah blah
yeah yeah I never understood that bro I
never understood that the people were so
quick to judge another guy and they'll
say oh bro he's a this man yeah
he's over here he married a single
mother or something like this like bro
at the end of the day it's between him
and Allah if he chose to marry this
woman he's going to be responsible for
this woman now he's gonna be responsible
for this kid or multiple kids and it's
like bro that's in and of itself that's
that's like a South Dakota or a sodak I
should say not a jolly but you get the
picture right so let me just do what you
want to do if you don't want to marry if
that's the outside of your preference
knock yourself out if it's your
preference start yourself out I just
don't see why we got to get involved in
type these types of conversations it
doesn't even make sense to me you know
it's the wildest thing okay you don't
like it don't then fine but now you got
to make it like a whole part of your
movement and okay fine
you want to make it part of your
movement or part of your entire like you
know speech that you put online 24 7.
what's that got to do with Muslims
because we don't see this in Islam
yeah bro I'm going to be honest never
taking that position I say it's
difficult I've done it
it's difficult
you know
now we start making statements about the
individual that have no Foundation
within the book of the Sunnah they're
very dangerous
yeah because now you're setting a new
president because now you're talking
about Muslims who are doing something
that's from the religion getting married
whether she's a single mother or not
whether she's virgin or not maybe she's
divorced or whatever else
again not your business and you're
making a negative connotation on him
you're making a negative opinion on him
for doing something halal
cave how where are you coming from with
this he could go out he'd go out and
make dinner
you could go out and make dinner with a
virgin you're gonna Clap Hands Where
what's the what's the determining line
here now yeah yeah and that's the thing
see that's the problem most people would
be okay with that they would be like
okay I'll just go and and some sisters
are the same when it comes to polishing
it's like I'd rather have him just you
know go to like a woman for a night and
sleep with her and don't marry her don't
marry her it's like ice bro I swear some
of these extreme red people of red pill
people are just as toxic and stupid as
the extreme feminists they say the same
exact things you know with women it's
like
don't my man can't be poligenous oh my
God you're in a Prejudice relationship
how dare you how could you you're
oppressed you're this you're a housewife
you don't work oh my God you're
oppressor you you had a child of 22 oh
my God how could you do that don't you
want to travel and see the world in Mars
and Jupiter and all the stupid stuff and
the guys are like oh my God you married
a divorce woman oh my God your wife you
know well I mean I hope they wouldn't
ever find out about something like this
in your personal life but like things
like oh she's not a virgin if they ever
hear that they're going to lose their
mind she's been divorced before she has
a kid it's like like this shows how
selfish you are as an individual how
selfish you are
let's say pleasure was normal right this
is why people got to stay in their own
Lanes man that's it right there brother
made a choice
yeah 100 let's let's say that polygeny
was was normal nowadays right and was
accepted how many single women would be
married now how many more children would
be taken care of now and have like a
male role model to look up to I think
that the father obviously the biological
father should be involved but just in
case he you know he's passed away or
he's not there or something there should
be that relationship with a with a role
model and that is fundamental that is
crucial to a good upstanding society
that is not broken and what we are
living is a dystopic society that's only
getting worse because of red pill yes
and because of feminism and all we need
is Islam to fix it and we've shared
practically why as well so far yeah
absolutely well just think about this
think about this for a second he's
whether it be a man or a woman who are
throwing dirt on another man or a woman
for their actions like imagine this
other person like imagine this guy he's
marrying this a single mother
and he's doing it for the sake of Allah
and imagine you as an individual
you are basically slander is it
slandering or is it what's the other
word it's this praise for something Meg
biting my bad my bad backbiting yeah
accept it so okay so let's say you as an
individual bro you are backbiting him
he's doing this for the sake of Allah
and you're backbiting him calling him a
cook for his action it's like bro
congratulations and now all of you're
gonna carry all his sins
this is a strange thing I don't I don't
have praise for it I don't have this
praise for it I just that's an
individual choice and it's a Halal one
and you know how am I gonna how am I
gonna crap on the guy for a Halal Choice
that's what he chose it's weird it's
strange it's very strange
um you know and again this is something
that's like contrary to Islam where do
we pick this ideology up you know what I
mean where do we get it from
why
yeah you don't have to okay don't clap
your hands but don't don't crap on the
guy either now you know what I mean it's
a really if you think about it from an
Islamic standpoint from the standpoint
and Muslims when you're looking at
Hadith when you look at the book of the
Sunnah when you're looking at Sierra
it's a weird position to take as a
Muslim maybe for a non-muslim okay knock
yourself out you guys think that kids
can change their gender also so so you
know it kind of makes sense y'all be mad
about some weird stuff you know another
individual chooses you know in that
regard but for us as Muslims it's
strange man to be strange and this is
you know
I guess this is where red pill is
infecting
the muscles
indeed you know where where it's like
let's say all Muslims were on the Quran
uh they wouldn't be reacting this way
they wouldn't be thinking this way and
they will see it and be like okay like
you do your thing right between Allah
but now you got the the red pill stuff
it's it's slowly infecting the minds of
Muslims especially young Muslims that's
the big picture is the young Muslims
indeed
foreign
RP says we're never going to get rid of
red pill simply because feminism is
never going away it's been forced onto
the world so hard but this goes back to
what I'm saying earlier it's like you
know this is where your betting comes in
where like you start eliminating women
who have feminist ideology or very
strong feminist ideology that you don't
think
can be um what's the word
um
like removed from her like expunged from
her through marriage why would you marry
somebody like that there's a lot of
sisters out there looking at married I'm
50 years old have multiple wives 10
children and I'm still getting proposals
guys there's a lot there you don't have
to just take whatever comes your way you
don't have to just accept whatever
I just today a sister she's 28 years old
she contacted me she's 28 years old
sister just come at me like Goofy with
this and I'm not bragging here but I'm
just giving you an example some
beautiful sister she's absolutely
gorgeous you know from North Africa but
she just came like all aggressive
whatever else how would I say you know
what
I told her so you seem very aggressive
you seem very upset you seem very angry
very masculine I said it's not really
what I'm looking for so I hope um you
know I hope you find what you're looking
for why do you have to deal with that
you don't have to deal with these types
of sisters you don't have to
but again it comes back to that entire
mentality of red pill rot it just puts
it into your head like you know oh this
is an amazing option issues ruined by
feminism and therefore
any option I get after this might not be
as good and they're all bad or or
something along those lines just I've
never seen like a very very very clear
line of thought from an Islamic
perspective you know when it comes down
to like you know reconciling the two
yeah yeah like I said I you know I'm not
you know I'll be a liar to say I didn't
benefit somewhat from red pill but again
I have my share of dams like I said that
I carry with me and I see it to this day
you know um that red pill Rock and I
have to really really check that I
really have to like okay
where is this coming from
why am I you know acting like this or
experiencing this right now and let me
let me walk back from this it's not easy
it's not easy you pick that stuff up and
it like it kind of stays with you
you know protect us and make it easy for
us it is it's hard when when you kind of
shape your whole reality based on one
world view and then have to make a
switch
um for us but I do want to point one
thing out on that same comment you're
responding to they said something like
you know red pill is not going anywhere
because feminism is not going anywhere
and and sorry I put that up by accident
but regardless
um you know if feminism's not going
anywhere uh and that stuff can you
imagine if the president had that
mentality idol worship is everywhere
it's not going to go anywhere you know
anything I do is going to be in vain and
bro he was literally the only Muslim on
the face of the Earth who believed in
Islam at a point in time right because
he was the first Muslim a first time and
then he went to his people and he
preached to them he got a small group he
he built them up to be good man to stand
up against idol worship to to call to
Islam properly and then they started
doing that he got his Elites and so on
and so forth they kept pushing it and
then eventually they they uh this is a
you know oversimplification eventually
they conquered Mecca they were you know
kind of given the authority in Medina
they everyone was Muslim so they
accepted them as a leader and then they
went and they conquered up to like you
know Rome and like the borders of China
and stuff
I'd love to get not top G on the show I
mean I know we said we would like to try
to do some callings that'd be amazing to
get them on here he said the Matrix got
you of America let me tell you something
red pill is the matrix it's part of the
Matrix 100 yeah
reactionary the feminism how is it not
part of a matrix Dude tell me how it's
made Western Society better for men in
general where have we seen the
Improvement of Western Society we
actually have all the red pill guys
talking about all the the the the 304s
out there
but they're out there making 304s with
what they learned from red pill
help me out man probably not the Matrix
100 100
and I would like for these people you
know these extreme red pillars and
extreme feminists to actually make an
actual case you know provide some kind
of argument don't give this weird
speculative garbage like like make a
comment that just does not have to do
with speculation make make actual points
don't just say oh the Matrix got him
that's such a cop-out to not have to
deal with what people are saying it's so
annoying like imagine imagine I looked
at you I'm like oh he's just a soy boy I
don't have to listen to what he's saying
it's like I don't think you really
appreciate that you'd want me to you
know engage in your with your comment
intellectually so we do invite you and
everyone else on the show inshallah we
were going to do a call in but I
realized that our our fan base is solely
basically Muslim we're not really going
to get a lot of red pill people jumping
on but if you guys want to jump on
inshallah we invite you just go to the
three Muslims Discord verify go down to
the call-in section and we will bring
you up inshallah I mean it's clear that
there's a lot of you know Pros in there
you know um pro pro uh red pill ideology
guys you know some of my know you know
what I mean some of these guys are on my
Discord you know like sulay I've known
filet for a long time nice brother
loving the death you know
you made the comment about it
pause for a second pause for a second
this guy who is saying that you are
basically the Matrix got you or
something like this and just listening
for a second all right let's say that
okay that for them red pill is like out
of the matrix it's like it is what it is
okay clearly this person has not looked
into red pill uh deep enough right it's
like you said when you start getting
really deep in the red pill number one
you get the red pill Rock number two you
start getting this bro this ridiculous
stuff like how we first said on the
stream where Rolo is over here saying
that every man needs to get a vasectomy
what kind of trash is this bro
and listen bro when I was into the
reptile stuff back in the day I started
really looking into it because again
like this stuff was making a lot of
sense
and the the deeper I got I actually
started finding out about things like
MGT like men going their own way and I
was like you know what exactly what you
said Ron I was like you know what I need
this in my life I need to be like this I
need to be strong I need to be going in
my own Direction I need to make more
money I need to make myself into
something in this life because it's not
given to me I have to create it in my
life and the deeper against this I got I
started looking into like mgtow channels
and bro some of these guys were saying
oh uh disregard women don't even talk to
women don't do anything with women yet
they're over here promoting like sex
dolls and uh pornography and all this
other stuff I'm like bro what the hell
is this man like this is so far off like
this this something's like not aligned
you know what I'm saying so it's like
for people who say that red pill is it
for people who say mgtow is it like
y'all y'all are clearly stuck in the
system and for them you to look at
someone who has left the system and say
ah bro you're you're in the system
you're in The Matrix like bro clearly
you haven't like looked into it that
much from The Matrix with multiple wives
ten kids mashallah decent career and
that's the Matrix then okay
I mean a lot of these guys okay actually
to the brother that commented that what
Define Matrix what is the Matrix when he
says in the Matrix what does that mean a
lot of these guys can't Define what the
Matrix is it's just a word that they
throw up when you know when they don't
like something oh that thing's bad yeah
that's a part of the Matrix what is the
Matrix
this is another problem you know it
oversimplifies complex problems
you know
um
if the woman responds the way I wanted
to positive if she doesn't respond away
I don't want her to 304.
and no maybe she just don't like you you
know there's a lot more to it than just
you know this over simplification okay
maybe that's a extreme
oversimplification that I've actually
thrown out there maybe that's a little
bit dishonest but really when you look
at a lot of the the public discourse
taking place out there this is like what
it boils down to you know and um
it's just yeah
it's all messy it would be nice to get
some of these guys on here though where
you guys at yeah I'm 100 we're waiting
on you guys go to the Muslim in this
Zone longer than me so I I'm I if
there's somebody out there who's been in
this entire
sphere longer than me as a Muslim I
please step forward you have something
to teach me
you guys heard it here first go to the
three Muslims Discord jump on the after
you verify jump on the uh the call-in
show in the waiting room and we'll bring
you in inshallah
but um I'm telling you bro a lot of
these guys I either they they agree with
you or they're too scared to come up
like that's what I realized about a lot
of these comments they will comment
they're on an anonymous account they'll
comment anything they they you know
their messed up mind will tell them to
and but they will never face you even
online don't they won't even let you
hear their voice yeah well by Channel I
have like live shows and I invite people
on and it's really the the the trolls
and the haters they they never come on
yeah
yeah 100 100 it's weird bro like I
sometimes I go live on Tick Tock and I
look for people you know to have
Interfaith discussions with and debate
I've been trying literally I will sit on
for an hour two hours a night like every
night for like a week or bi-weekly and
like I just I have not spoken to anyone
in like forever people just don't want
to talk
welcome back
yeah some reason I think he's bugging up
to my other house because I stayed
between houses obviously with multiple
wise to actually be able to broadcast
here because the connection the place
with my other computer just doesn't
really work right so we'll mail a bus if
you're doing that bro we appreciate it I
think it's been a great stream so far
yeah can you recommend some good Sierra
and Hadith translations
um translations of Sierra and Hadith um
people say the sealed nectar is good I
don't really know a good pseudo book in
English to be honest
um Hadith translations I don't think
there's really
they're the the popular Publications uh
they're just not coming to my mind do
you guys know any
um
no when it comes down translations I
mean what do you guys call Dar Salam
they have the yeah yeah
you know did they have out multi-volumes
those who tend to be good they tend to
be like you know recommended by a lot of
Intolerable M that I know
um
those two right off the bat I mean if
you if you're a regular person those
books keep you occupied for the rest of
your life probably you know um so I mean
those from Dara Salaam uh uh I think the
bukhari is like nine volumes is it I
can't remember anymore I have it I love
the guitar I forgot it there and The
Abridged Muslim is no so bukhari is like
12 volumes and The Abridged Muslim is
like end or something yeah you spend a
lifetime reading those men yeah and I
want to give people kind of a tip when
reading unless you're like just an Avid
Reader and like you're cool and reading
all the time
um if you're like me and like you just
didn't grow up reading that much like
you struggled a little bit
um or like you don't have a great
tension span don't fall into the um the
habit of feeling like you need to read
every word on the page and start at the
beginning and go word by word all the
way to the end you can skim through a
book sometimes and get a decent
understanding you can skim through
paragraphs and ask I I to ask my teacher
about this this is the chair I asked him
about it he told me you should skim
through the headings skim through the
subtitles skim through the text and then
focus on anything you you think will be
super beneficial because a lot of times
the intros to these books you could skip
through obviously with Hadith you can't
really do that with the Quran you can't
do and that's one thing by the way side
note I love about the Quran you can't
skim through it it's not like a
chronological thing you know in the
beginning was Adam then you say okay let
me skip to Newark you can't skim through
it
that's why I think it's so beautiful
Hadith is similar it's just a bunch of
narrations
now you can skip to the book you want
the book of marriage or something
other than that yeah it's packed full of
information it takes a long time to
focus on
yeah
sorry I went on a little right there
well I guess uh there's no tapers huh
I'm telling your brothers I'm sorry
these people are scared man these red
pill people they're they're actually
scared to talk
our red pill is men that English
I used to be an English teacher
we remove the r put the is at the
beginning is red pill one of the fitness
of the the general wow man you gotta ask
the olamide that's right yeah I think I
think there's this weird notion with the
job that like he's not an actual being
he's not an actual person but it's just
all the misguidance that's happening
today on one side yeah it starts to make
sense but then when you get to the
Hadith that talks about Jesus Ali said
I'm physically like thrusting his Spirit
into him and him traveling the Earth in
40 days and like it just doesn't make
sense so okay safe there has a good
question
um advice for brothers stuck in the red
pill sphere you know there's this little
joke out there well I'll say this
because I was in that that thing they
say go out and touch grass
straight up bro it's actually more real
than you think now I'm not saying
literally go outside and touch the grass
bro I mean if you want to look weird to
your neighbors knock yourself out if you
do that but you actually bro there's
nothing there's nothing for you online
you got to go out and you got to live
bro you know as a man who's been to like
51 countries you know speaks multiple
languages and all this type of stuff and
I'm not it's not bragging I'm just
telling you there's nothing that you're
going to
learn online that you won't learn 10
times faster by actually going out into
the world and experiencing it going out
into the world the next you see what
happens is is the internet becomes a
buffer for your fears
guys are afraid to actually go and try
and approach a family about marriage or
go to a sister and say hey you know what
I want to talk to your Wally whatever
else and so what do you do you use the
internet red pill all these talks from
other guys talking to women talking
about women as a buffer
to not actually face your fears 100 I'm
telling you I've seen it so many times
Brothers will tell you that we're in my
men's Community that's now turned into
the Discord I'm like yo you Brothers
have been in this room we've got a room
and it's called a bird trap and a bird
trap it's a joke it's a play on words
because the British call a woman a bird
it's like how to trap a bird how to get
a wife basically so it's a plan words
and it's the most active group we've got
money we've got Fitness we've got
multiple rooms where we talk about
different topics but the most active one
is the bird trap and I'm like when are
you Brothers gonna stop talking and
going to ask you to get married
as I stop talking this is like a buffer
this entire red pill sphere is a buffer
to actually going out and getting what
you want in life you can't you can't
Lark this you can't live action role
play any of this go out
and actually go for what you want
that you're going to learn 10 times
faster sometimes it's painful but you
know what it's supposed to be
how are you going to learn anything
without pain you're a man you have to
experience it
and I'm not saying go out and like
damage yourself and get like you know
trauma that's not what I'm saying but
how do you improve as a man
you experience something you learn from
it and then you continue right you don't
give up you don't throw in a towel my
wife is sitting right over here she's
she's been with me for like six and a
half seven years we've gone from
absolute poverty to now it's like well
you know we were in the store yesterday
and she was like I was like I'd like to
buy this he's like why are you doubting
it it's like I've had that mentality of
like you know like hey I ain't got the
money towards like why would I have to
second guess a purchase like this
inflation this that the other and she
was just like she reminded me you know
you have to go through these experiences
or you won't grow
the internet thing watching Myron talk
to a bunch of girls all the stuff that I
love my earned to death I talked to him
he was like the first person that he was
on my show first when he introduced the
show when he introduced fresh and fit it
did it on my channel
I've known Myra in that long so any guys
watching that what are you doing well
you're just using as a buffer not to ah
but women she's just a 304 anyway I
don't need to talk to her oh she's a
famous I don't need to talk to her
because
she said something that sounded like
something I heard on my own show bro all
of that stuff
hey Kudos set up for their popularity or
the show whatever else but I'm telling
you a 90 of these guys out here using it
as a buffer to actually go out and
experience life instead of 100 you know
so go out and touch grass bro a lot of
golf we actually do have somebody who
joined the calling show
um it doesn't really have a name I can
read out loud to be honest but I do want
to bring him up inshallah first we gotta
help please your red pills make me very
angry at women
there you go whoa who's playing the
stream back because I can hear myself
Gordo brother can you uh mute please
I'll read that while you're doing that
help please repo is making me very angry
woman how can I stop listening to red
pill because it makes me hate women
thanks
you know what's going to make you you
know what
you know what I mean I hate to say this
this is what happened to me I didn't
really ever ever hate women but I ended
up like getting hurt dealing with women
that I wanted
yeah I have women I wanted now don't get
me I want no don't get me wrong that's
what I'm saying but you know when you
actually lose something that you want
this comes back to out touching grass
type of thing it's like it's gonna make
you want to let it go you're gonna start
like questioning like okay why didn't
that work because this comes back to the
baggage that you pick up
why on Earth
would you start to hate women
I mean just really think about that
statement
what part of normal is that
my entire journey through all that stuff
and then in it and then out the back
door of it has never involved the hatred
of women there has been moments of anger
but then again it comes back to like
okay I actually want to be with women
that's why I have multiple women I love
women so it's like why would I actually
want to be angry at women it's gonna
totally poison the way you deal with
them it's going to block your ability to
have a relationship with women you have
to really embed that into your mind and
think okay this is a this is no longer
aiding me this is hindering me this is
that red pill rod
okay I'm getting that going out too
so you see you really just need to take
the action you I don't know what again
this comes back to the fear bro and just
you know don't take it as an attack
please take it as a piece of advice
you're afraid to go out and expose
yourself to like rejection
and and that's why you're afraid to
leave that sphere because this fear puts
up a nice buffer between you and
rejection the pain of rejection the fear
of rejection it's great because it makes
you feel good because like oh yeah he
told her he showed her you know you get
rejected oh yeah she's like that girl
nah just let all that go bro it's part
of the process
you know as part of the process you have
to go through it you got to face the
rejection you got to face the fear and
you got to be able to come out of it
without pain hurt anger or whatever else
because it's a right of a person a woman
or otherwise to actually reject you and
not want you not want to be with you to
treat you with disrespect it's their
right but it's also your right not to
have to tolerate it you don't need red
pill to like accept that that's just
self-respect and dignity
yeah 100 100 percent
so I'm trying to um I'm trying to set up
the call-in show so the way I do it is
you guys if you want you can hop on
Discord and then we can all talk there
or I can try and share it on here and
also share it with them on Discord so
you can hear each other
um but that is a little bit difficult
you might hear a bit of echo once you
know with me getting it set up but I'm
gonna try my best inshallah so let's see
can I get somebody in the call and show
to talk we got a few people here Chef
Gordo pxy
and then I'm not even gonna try
pronouncing that
oh yeah oh yeah all right
can one of y'all just uh say something
hello all right I heard I heard someone
all right I heard someone for a second
so
let me try and bring Angel up now I'm
gonna try and share my screen for a
second bear with me
hey can you hear me oh wait I'm muted
can you guys hear me
okay all right perfect so let me
add this here
okay now one of y'all talk can Abu
American and on Hill hear the chat
someone say something
you keep cutting in and out I'm cutting
in and out okay I do hear it yeah you
hear them okay now can you guys hear my
side can you guys hear like Abu American
and those guys
yeah we can hear you
okay can you hear the other guys though
I think they're muted
okay wait Abu American say something uh
I'm not muted but we can hear you oh
okay I got you so let me just
I think that's what I gotta do here
okay yeah his uh microphone is muted
okay Abu American say something please
uh I'm here
okay did you guys hear that
okay I need a representative from you
guys uh choosy Pandora you didn't hear
you didn't hear him no I don't see his
thing turn green but I don't hear any
sound oh I didn't hear him okay I got
you so part you guys might hear a little
bit of echo if it gets too annoying let
me know but I think that's the only way
I can do this right now
I think you guys got to lower your uh
microphone sensitivity
okay
[Music]
okay that's my fault
do you guys want to just jump on the
Discord instead then I've been working
you have Discord yeah
um
want to do it
there are too many people in here I'm
gonna have to put some in the waiting
room for now
um or once we start
so uh maybe you know discuss amongst
yourselves who who you guys want to be
the first
so I'm gonna stay on the show for this
or oh wait um
if you don't mind just step in the
waiting room that'd be that'd be
appreciated um Abu America why don't you
just jump on Discord turn your camera
and mic on there and then I'll share the
screen here
yeah if you don't mind
Charlie uh on can you send me the can
you send me the link yeah let me get it
for you
uh I can drag you guys there
my Discord is up
um
okay copy all right I'm just gonna start
dragging random people to the waiting
room
wait wait
wait
okay and boom I think that's a good
start
all right uh telegram's fine bro yeah
all right absolutely
there you go you're gonna have to verify
uh once you join but that shouldn't take
too long inshallah hopefully not
um let me see
I appreciate everyone's patience while
we set this up quickly
Echo time yeah that was my bad it's not
gonna Echo inshallah
okay pass the verification so I'm in
here and then where is the room
scroll down in the channels and you'll
see uh the call and show area
production I just closed Discord
uh
leave leave the stream from here and
then join on Discord okay
all right
all right and then there was one
alhamdulillah
okay
yeah this is usually just the smoothest
way to do it
so uh
I guess we'll get it done this way
inshallah
all right gentlemen can you guys hear me
hello hello can you guys hear me
American I think you're muted
or is this my end
that might be mine my mind
okay my bad guys it has that much better
yeah it was my fault okay making sure
the chat can hear everyone I think um I
think that was gonna be good inshallah
okay now I can't hear you for some
reason you can't hear me
the yeah my mic is working so you should
be able to
use your settings I think it's on his
own then
no it's good okay so everyone can hear
everyone I think except Abu American
all right uh Gordo can you hear me bro
there we go along my back man
uh you're muted
yeah I'll put the best out here we go
okay I should be over here okay sorry I
think okay there we go
now I can hear you all right I finally
getting this thing going alhamdulillah
it's a little bit complicated but we got
it we got it eventually that's all that
matters
all right perfect
oh I can turn my camera on to that sick
beautiful
let me Focus this up there we go oh
maybe we should just stream on Discord
for now on bro it makes things easier
yeah there you go all right perfect and
uh p x y my friend can you uh
turn on your mic you don't have to turn
your camera on if you don't want to
though
are we continuing on the same topic of
is uh RP compatible with Islam or are we
continuing on something else yeah I mean
it's going to be the whole topic of red
pill if you want to talk about you know
if he agrees the slam or not then we can
do that as well if it lines I was just
gonna answer the question that was on
the title if that's all right yeah go
for it brother
also assalamu alaikum and thank you guys
for your uh lovely content I actually I
believe I found Abu American through you
guys and Mahdi a couple months before I
became Muslim about 16 months ago so
quite quite a journey in fact may Allah
bless you my brother alhamdulillah
welcome to Islam thank you brother and
so I was going to say
um so I'm 24 now and I actually pardon
me I lost my voice a couple days ago
food poisoning
um I got into red pill I guess they're
learning pickup and game when I was 15
and I'm 24 now and so I was agnostic at
the time and my family is Christian and
I began to explore that and it took me
away from religion I feel like for a
minute but then when my friend gave me
dawa when I was 23 I realized
largely a lot the good aspects of RP
here I don't know if you can say the
word do the algorithm but it is uh quite
compatible with the proper practice of
Islam but
honestly a person should just follow
authentic sunnen and the Quran rather
than waste many years in the pickup
artist or RP space because honestly they
get a lot of things right but they they
get the promiscuity aspect wrong you
know RP is correct that Western divorce
courts generally are a bad idea and
legal marriage can often have bad
consequences if applied wrong
um and that dread game
um and competition anxiety is a real
thing
amongst women and that you know the
truth that women like intimacy more than
men usually and that um you know truths
like this that are not typically
discussed you know women like dominance
and often what you know vanilla people
might call like depraved acts in
intimacy things that the blue pill
things don't really discuss but you know
a lot of young men are wasting time
unnecessarily on the red pill when there
is a far superior infinitely Superior
Dean a way of life uh to follow
can I interject yeah yeah so this goes
into like I mean and you know this
because you know we talk regularly I
think you know um when it comes down to
like Western ports and Western divorce
what's the solution
because I discussed this a lot right
so what do I say
do you remember
I would say it's best to avoid the legal
paperwork as best as you can or to find
you know maybe another Visa of sorts
yeah avoid Western marriage because
Western marriage from the legal sense
does not benefit the Muslim in any way
shape or form legal marriage doesn't
make a woman permissible to you Islamic
marriage does
you see it to me and if you're
islamically married then
a the woman's allowed to you so what do
you need a legal marriage for if a woman
doesn't understand this basic concept
you shouldn't be dealing with him
I mean that's just a basic like
principle right there it's like why does
she need a legal marriage from the West
there's only one reason why you need a
legal marriage from the West it's so
that you can Divorce Court destroy that
brother
well why would you marry a woman like
that in the first place because it makes
no sense you can any country that I know
of in the west you can register the name
of the father on the birth certificate
you know what I mean whether you're
married or not because they have common
law they have you know all these types
of stuff where people are living
together for years having children
together okay well islamically we fit
that category so you see what I'm saying
red pill again this comes back to what I
was saying okay red pill yeah we've got
all this information out here red pills
you'll get destroyed in the divorce
court but for Muslims
why am I going to legally marry for what
unless it serves a purpose like maybe
you've got a woman out here and you want
to a certain country you know and so you
need the marriage to bring her out here
but in general if you're out here in the
west there's absolutely no reason
systems should be demanding legal
marriages and if she is then if that's
not a big enough red flag for you to
avoid her
it's a sign of needing she doesn't have
enough genuine desire for the man to not
just want the deal as it is in halal the
way it was intended needing to have
state leverage whether she knows it or
not and you know you may not have a good
woman initially and then she could put
State leverage on when things go awry
potentially yeah I want to jump
yeah so I disagree with this because I
think that it focuses too much on the
male perspective it doesn't actually
look into what you know why the women do
it 100 I think there are women out there
that have bad intentions that just want
to be able to have some kind of control
or leverage in cases it can be red flags
a lot of the sisters what they worry
about is if they only get the Nika and
not the legal marriage then there is no
State holding the man accountable for
his injustices towards her under the
Islamic law if a man is unjust towards
his wife islamically speaking because
the injustices don't always translate if
a man's Injustice or unjust to his wife
islamically speaking it's not like you
know you can go to him you can go to the
the court and say oh you know he he
didn't give him my rights he didn't pay
for the groceries he didn't cover the
basic necessities they're going to say
who cares you're a grown woman you could
do it yourself you know you're liberal
that's not fair you know and and there
are cases may even people don't think it
happens often there are cases where men
just completely like leave their wives
and children go off with somebody else
and these are things that at least
sisters are worried about so it's not
always the case that you know they ask
for legal marriage because they uh you
know they have some bad intention
but yeah
I understand but then we come back again
to the whole system of like the Wally so
now my daughter let's say she gets
married to an unjust husband well what's
my position here now it's my position to
like go to him and say hey look bro
you're not treating my daughter properly
why
what's preventing you from this and if I
can't get a rectifiable answer or
situation you know a situation that
leads to rectification of what I say I
said hey look you know what we we did
this to our cloudy we're gonna we're
gonna undo this by Audi because
obviously you can't be just you know the
thing is this the legal system can't
they they can't
invoke or or bring about Islamic rights
in the Islamic household they're not
going to be really interested is what
I'm saying it's like you know well he he
doesn't pay the rent or he demands I
play half well you see what I'm saying
the court would be like well what's
wrong with that most people you know the
husband and wife play half and half you
know what I mean she has no grounds or
foundation islamically in the legal
court system of the West because it's
too for lack of a better term
androgynous in terms of like equality so
it's very problematic so for me I I just
for me I don't see the benefit of it and
if he is unjust and there is no there's
no recourse well that's what you almost
for also because there's people online
I'd I'd love to in a in both a general
and a literal sense I'd love to punch in
the face but I get my Huck from them on
normal for their backbiting and their
and their agree but I don't get to punch
him in the nose you know yeah I'm being
I'm using hyperbole here but you
understand what I'm saying you know this
is why you almost exists like if there's
unjustice between co-wives you know a
husband he's unjust between his wives
well what are the losses what it was
said about him he'll be raised up on Yom
okay I'm a twisted and distorted and
he'll ask his Lord why am I twisted and
distorted when I was healthy and in good
health in in the Dunya because you were
unjust between your wives so this is not
really the doing is not the place to get
your Justice in that sense I'm not
saying that we should accept unjustice
you know and that we should allow for
our sisters to be mistreated that's not
what I'm saying but there are clear
punishments you know
um listed within the book of the Sun
that say Hey look if you're unjust to
your wife you you better be careful
Kentucky law fear Allah and if you don't
okay we take the woman back and your
family is your day so for me the Western
legal thing is kind of like I understand
there's benefits to it I'm legally
married to my wife here but because she
needs a Visa because she's not from a
country that like allows her to travel
to Germany or Europe you know very
easily
I understand situation like that but in
fact you're both from America is to me
it seems like hmm
yeah I was gonna say
I understand both of your points
like when we're talking about the uh the
rights and everything a woman shouldn't
have to depend on something that's not
Islamic in order to get her rights you
know like I understand okay yeah like it
will give the rights to the woman you
know if the woman goes to the judge and
says so and so of course like having the
legal stuff is is gonna help
well let's be honest it's like
it's like her brother I was saying it it
should really only be utilized if there
is a direct reason to get married maybe
it's for Visa purposes maybe it's for
okay you're about to have children
you're going to be you're gonna have a
child uh not even in the state that of
which you are going to be in you're
going to be in a completely different
state so you need to have that Visa so
that when you come into the state let's
say you have to be in there for five
months how can you be in there for five
months if the Visa that you can only get
upon arrival is maybe one month maybe
two or three months you see what I'm
saying so it's like when there's a
reason that's when doing a legal
marriage in my eyes it seems the most uh
understandable but then if there is no
reason well then then the cast serves
its purpose because it's it's
islamically how it should be and if if
for some reason a man is just not
upholding his thing
I mean she has the right to divorce or
not
okay so you know let me I feel like
there's two maybe three people like on
your side and only one of me on my side
so I think it's fair that I get to
respond to each point inshallah
um also I'm gonna ask I don't know why
people are jumping back in the actual
call uh can you guys wait go in the
waiting room inshallah it's filling up
too much and I know this is the big
topic everyone wants to jump in I
understand but we'll bring you up
accordingly inshallah guys anyone who
just jumped in please go in the waiting
room I appreciate it very much
um now yeah so I mean on the topic of
like Injustice and that stuff the woman
will also be held accountable you know
if she is unjust and she like wrongfully
steals the half the man stuff so it's
like I understand the argument it can go
both ways
um all I'm saying and let me Begin by
saying what we all agree on the Islamic
system is perfect the problem here is
that we live in a cover system a
disbelieving system with man-made
horrible laws that and sometimes favor
men sometimes favor women like for
example with with the court uh who gets
custody a lot of the time women are
favored and if a woman says oh I was
hurt or I was you know hit or something
like that and most of the time they will
believe her there are many issues the
100 percent
but that doesn't expel the fact that
there are a lot of women and by the way
let me add that we can't conflate like
for example non-muslim statistics which
a lot of people you guys haven't brought
up a lot of people tend to do that with
the Muslims in the west because they're
non-muslims outnumber Muslims in the
west many times over
I apologize my camera and they're going
out they they outnumber us many times
over so if we're using their statistics
that doesn't exactly represent our
community you know think about it why
would a woman who comes from a culture
that shuns women for getting divorce
divorce you know or being divorced or
initiating divorce why would she want to
get a divorce if unless she actually you
know is being you know harmed or
something like that in that case now
again I'm not saying that she should
have the righteous to take half the
stuff I think that's egregious that's
horrible but at the same time this is
why some sisters would push for it so to
paint them as like oh they're all just
kind of red flags or they all have bad
intentions I don't think is is correct
now I want to give one last thing
islamically if we lived in a Sharia
abiding country
and a woman said I want to put a clause
in the marriage contract that if you
divorce me I take half your stuff
that's Halal and if for some reason some
weird reason a mammals accept that
that's Halal she can ask and he can
accept there's nothing wrong with it so
what some Scholars say is when a man
gets married legally he is implicitly
signing off on that unless he States
otherwise uh contrary to the Western Law
um it's not going to go that way and
that's where the idea of prenups and
that stuff come in I understand they're
not always you know wholehearted and
hold up but they are an option 100 and I
just want to bring more the sisters out
of things because a lot of the time it
gets overlooked no yeah no I understand
what you're saying um allow me to
disagree but based off one reason and
which is because and this is this is not
a red photography point this is I've
actually experienced this I've gone
through like a pretty a pretty
destructive
um divorce myself uh that was backed by
Western Law and that that's that's the
heart of the issue is that
in the divorce if my husband's unjust
the woman can can you know go through a
Wally she can get a Fuller and she can
go on with her life but in Western Law a
brother can get destroyed
you see what I mean so I'm I'm finally
the past year I'm finally back on track
to where I should be several years
behind but I'm back on track to where I
should be after 11 years of recovery
it took 11 years bro to give back to
where I should be so that means I should
technically be past where I'm at right
now
I'm doing very well so it can destroy
your life as a man the legal system but
generally an Islamic divorce does it
really destroy the life of a sister
there's always going to be a brother
that's going to marry a single mother
that's going to marry a divorce you you
see what I mean and so I just think it's
it's
I've been with I've been in enough
divorces I've been married in the Middle
East I've been married out here I know
that women they get very emotional they
make decisions that are very Brash that
don't make sense at the moment and later
on they're like I don't know what I was
thinking when I did that because they
are very emotional creatures and I think
that's a very very dangerous weapon to
put in the hand to somebody who's like
you know who who's whose entire life and
decisions are dictated on my feelings
dictate the reality of the world I live
in you know what I mean yeah that's just
my that's my stance I mean I understand
your position
um
but yeah there's there's that it's very
it's very dangerous position to put over
somebody I'll give you an example just
and if you don't mind allow me to rant
yeah like I said I'm in you know lower
executive position yesterday I'm leaving
my compound
and a security guard who's doing his job
he he asked me for some documentation
the guy should recognize me and she just
wave me through you know
but he didn't
and I just blew up on him I had a bad
day I had a whole bunch of stuff going
on and I mean a phone call I could have
this poor guy fired he's probably you
know I don't know what he's doing in
life he's trying to whatever else it's
it in a moment of motion I almost called
and had the guy fired first for him
doing his job just because he didn't
recognize me you know and I had to
actually drive out and I drove back and
I apologize I said you know what man I
said I had a really crappy day and I
just took it out on you this I said it's
not right and I said I apologize you
know I was like you know you're doing
your job thank you for doing your job
properly
I'm gonna put this in a relationship
where people have emotions involved
feelings running high and everything and
you give them this entire deadly weapon
of the legal system
it's dangerous it's dangerous like I
said I'm very conscious of myself and my
behaviors and so I knew what happened
that I was mad about something else and
I took it out on this poor guy just
imagine people who aren't so very
self-aware and they just take this
entire legal system and they've ripped
someone's life into pieces yeah you know
okay and then there's no consequence
your life goes on next week next month
whatever when your if that's over and
this brother he's struggling to put the
pieces back together for the next 11
years that was me I've experienced it
you know so this this I mean I
understand what you're saying bro and
I'm you know we're not obviously we're
just having a healthy conversation here
uh but I would say you know take that
into consideration with legal marriage
in the west you know um that emotions
they play very very ugly tricks on
people you know
um and once it's initiated you can't
take it back yeah first thing I have a
question I have a question if anyone
knows it please come in
um when let's say uh a man in a man
assistant a woman and a man get married
yeah they get a legal marriage let's say
they're gonna get a divorce now you know
how the legal thing is where uh the
woman is going to take way more than
what she should islamically speaking
does she have the ability to say you
know what no I'm not going to take all
this I'm just going to leave it at this
much or just leave it at nothing yeah
she does right yeah yes yes you can it
let's say you're in you're in the U.S
right you could go with your woman to
the divorce court and just sign off and
have it be done an uncontested divorce
is what they would call it yeah indeed
okay okay so then I see
um two options and by all means one we
don't don't take this with me like
trying to cut the flow of everything I
was just kind of throwing out what's in
my mind right now well option number one
is like uh the brother could get a
a prenup
if she truly truly feels like the need
for it before getting the legal marriage
or I think you can even do it after if
I'm correct I have no idea I'm very
ignorant when it comes to this but a
prenup would pretty much solve that
issue where okay if the divorce does
happen well then it's going to be it's
gonna end up the same way as it would
islamically speaking if it was just
Anika or if he doesn't do the prenup
then he's placing the
the trust in her that she will be
God-fearing that she will fear of love
when the time comes if ever the time
comes when the divorce might happen that
she is going to you know what no Islamic
leads if not how it's going to be so I'm
just going to take this much and then
we're gonna cut it off
nice and easy but then again this is
this is just what I'm seeing from my own
uh understanding but again I'm very
ignorant please normally go ahead
because I know you were about to jump in
on something yeah so uh I think those
are great points
um so I've been working first and
foremost blessing to reward you um I'm
very sorry that happened I I definitely
see that that is a the horrible downside
to legal marriage I think that there are
downsides like I mentioned
um so may Allah reward you and Elevate
you for going through that and allow you
you know to excel in every way Allah I
mean and for all of us and the young men
out there as well I'm in Europe uh I do
want to say
actually I took something else because I
don't want to miss anything
um I so I don't 100 advocate for I don't
say every single man should especially
if a man's gonna be poligenous you
actually can't legally and these Western
Nations right so I don't say
am I cutting out for people
yeah there's a little bit of traffic
okay yeah my bad I don't know if it's
Wi-Fi or if it's the mic but I thought
it was just me but I guess everyone else
has seen the job as well is it better
now
we can usually hear what you're saying
in in between the chops okay okay that's
good so
yeah so I don't 100 advocate for it I
think generally speaking
um I think generally speaking it's good
for the average person I I think for the
average woman it's understandable if she
wants it because of the reasons we're
gonna give so first and foremost you
mentioned you know completely ruins a
man's life it could also completely ruin
a woman's life if she doesn't because
let's say you know she births three
children uh she doesn't have a legal
marriage
and then the guy just like you know
leaves her or whatever
now she's left with three children take
care of it and there's no legal
responsibility no accountability she
can't even divorce him and take anything
um because he you know he's just left or
whatever
you know her name is not on any of the
the assets or blah blah whatever
whatever like women end up in those
situations it maybe it doesn't happen
super often but it does happen
it is something that uh women are
fearful of so I think that at the very
least that's something that should be
you know recognizing these discussions
uh so their lives can also be ruined uh
divorced women especially in our like
you know the Desi and Arab culture they
are horribly stigmatized and this is
something that you mentioned earlier
that like you know if you married a
divorced woman other brothers will look
at you like yo what the heck's wrong
with you and all that stuff including
Muslim guys who maybe follow red pill so
why would a woman want you to throw
yourself in that position randomly if
she is completely happy or like decently
happy with her husband just to get some
you know just to get a bag or something
like that I don't think that's
reasonable for maybe not Muslim women it
is but not for uh for Muslim women and
then also on the point that you know
women can be like emotional and just
take someone to corn take out their
stuff and it's undoable I agree but a
man can as well you know uh let's say
he's not legally married to her he can
threaten divorce that's why we have
three to Locks that's why some Scholars
say that you know if you say to lock
three times in one sitting it actually
just counts as one
because men get emotional and say okay
you're divorced yeah you're divorced
you're divorced twice that's how
emotional he is uh and then after that
it's you can't do anything about it so
islamically she's divorced because he
was emotional like and then there's no
legal system
to uh you know to to hold the man
accountable or to protect the
uh the woman in that case if he does
divorce her he can just you know
completely leave be with another woman
and she's left alone not being taken
care of or anything like that and I
think that's an injustice and I think
that if men are really maintainers
Protectors of women
that they shouldn't necessarily have a
firm issue with against against this
with every single woman because there
could be a chance that she would be left
unprotected because the legal system
won't cover her
but again I'm not saying it's a firm
thing for every single person
hope my mic was clear enough inshallah
yeah Mike was definitely couldn't now
bro before you continue I just want to
say I have to get going love you all for
the sake of Allah but
I could try and keep I can try and bring
other people in here and keep it going I
personally do have to um
get going in a minute but you know for
the sake of the call-in show we didn't
really have any guests so I do want to
bring you know all the people up
inshallah after you uh you respond uh
we're American
foreign
I was gonna ask can you make the call
and show private so we can bring people
in here and they can't just jump in
oh my God
I can't make it private so the thing is
can you text me because your car sound
is cutting off a country
okay I'll text you let's try here's one
word
okay
but uh I'm American Gordo can you guys
hear me can the chat here yeah
oh could I chime in and respond if
that's all right yeah of course I do
have to leave soon but inshallah of
course you can jump in okay yes
um what you're saying is true women
women don't want the unfortunate
situation of a man unjustly leaving and
a man doesn't want a situation of a
woman unjustly leaving with his resource
and that's why it's another uh red P
tenet typically they say that the sexual
strategies of men and women are often
conflicting we want generally what the
other has and usually
uh to get what you want there making
some degree of sacrifice
um but you know the solution is really
to follow the Islamic process you know
ideally if a woman finds a man through
her Wali or a righteous man through the
Masjid and he's connected to the
community even if there is not Western
legal penalties for this divorce uh he
will still be judged by the community
and there will be consequences in in you
know in the community it's it's not a
no-fault thing but I definitely agree
but um I think it it produces like
you're overcompensating for this problem
with uh Haram Western Court uh solution
because honestly the number of men that
leave women in their family unjustly is
much much much lower even though it's
still terrible is much much much lower
than the number of women that initiated
divorces now one could say maybe those
women had a good reason to initiate
those divorces in many cases a lack of
proper uh male leadership but honestly
for me the uh I would love to get
legally married but it's like having
your nuts on a chopping block and you're
giving this knife to this woman and
saying like I trust you you know she
might be a very trustworthy woman but
are you going to be entirely comfortable
with her having this nuclear option of
wasting months and years of your time
and and thousands of dollars of your
assets in court even if you do not
necessarily lose the uh disputed assets
it's just uh it's a risky thing you know
and my ex-wife she actually didn't
initiate like a court case against me
this is just the government coming
against me because we divorced she
didn't initiate anything against me this
court system just came for me
they're just like we've decided this is
your child support
they decided that she didn't she was
like I don't need it he sends me money
you know bro it was it was really messy
so she doesn't even have to actually
take action direct action against you
the state can just do it because they
can and you know we know about these
guys they're just their sense of justice
is very scary yeah oh one thing I wanted
to add to that you mentioned 11 years
for you to financially recover that's
interesting because I was listening to
Mr Aaron Clary yesterday and he cited to
statistic I need to find the real source
for it but allegedly on average it takes
a man 15 years in the United States to
recover financially from the average
divorce proceeding and I believe the
average divorce proceedings in
California cost about 100 000 US dollars
and that's just contesting the assets
that's not necessarily the division of
the assets that is just the because you
have to pay for your lawyer you have to
pay for the lawyer of the other party
you have to pay for all the you know if
there's kids involved you have to pay
for the lawyers that investigate the
relationships with the children and the
parents uh forensic attorneys to go
through your taxes forensic attorneys to
go through your personal life you know
it I think if people saw the intricacies
of Courts and the hell and the amount of
people that kill themselves are
completely derail their lives off of um
after court proceedings and the hell
that it is uh I'm not saying you're
foolish for going into it I think you
have good intentions and may Allah
protect all of us in our marriages but
it's just currently a risky situation in
the majority of states and in the
majority of Western countries yeah
oh sorry I think he cut out for a bit
okay he's back yeah and I I never I
never I never said that it wasn't I do
agree that it is it is a risk but I'm
saying that the risk is also both ways
right
um so on there's a few points but I
believe it's disproportionate okay okay
let me so let me respond kind of you
know Point by point because I think
these are fair points I do want to you
know be able to discuss mashallah so
firstly on the topic of you know the
Islamic way is best we don't have the
Islamic way yeah in the first few steps
you have the nikah and the witnesses and
all yeah okay we have that but
afterwards what do you have no male
accountability a lot of times no female
accountability as well you know there's
no State Islamic State enforcing
anything after the marriage there's only
the governmental state which is why okay
the first few stops are cool but okay
let's think long term what happens after
that that stuff is important as well and
that's why I'm making the case that I'm
making in regards to the statistics this
is why I made this point because a lot
of people bring up the statistics
um let me let me with another statistic
the the percentage of divorced
non-muslims is 11 the percentage of
divorced Muslims is six percent right
almost half so half the amount of
Muslims are divorced
so why are we
how and and to be fair that's not saying
the divorce rate is half I'm not saying
that I'm saying there are single not
married never married and divorced I'm
just saying that the amount of Muslims
who get married
and then divorce is definitely lower
right in the amount of divorce Muslims
is half about in America so using normal
some statistics to talk about Muslims
and Muslim Community with different
cultures it's not it's fallacious
because how many non-muslims are there
in America how many Muslims are there in
America so you're using non-muslims with
their kuffar not just system but their
beliefs as well you know women a lot of
women are praised non-muslim women are
actually praised a lot of time for
divorcing men I apologize for my camera
they're actually praised for divorcing
men taking half their stuff ruining
their life and like oh you're empowered
are Muslim women praised the same way a
lot of the time in their cultures no a
lot of the time they are shunned and a
woman I would I would argue that a woman
who who is divorced whether she takes
half the stuff or not is a lot more
shunned in her community and looked at
weird and it's harder for her to get
married
especially socially than a man who
divorces and basically neglects his wife
I feel it's a lot easier for a man even
if he neglect his last wife to be able
to get married again compared to a woman
who's been divorced before especially if
she has a kid
no I hear you
um obviously I disagree
but that's fair we were allowed to do
that right and remain cordial
um
my thing is this that lack of
protections for lack of a better term
has always existed since the time of
Muhammad sallallahu there's never been
like an in state enforcement you know
there's really unless it's been like an
Islamic communal type of like
retribution if that's the right word to
use
this protections they've never really
existed do you you know what I mean and
I it's my humble estimation
that it's by Design not by like accident
because you know obviously a lot of
Muhammad
of now so he knew what was going to
happen now later on with the legal
systems living in the west the changes
in the society but a lot you know he
didn't
put in any sort of extra steps or
whatever else so I you know this is this
is my opinion you know I'm I'm I don't
think people should just like be out
doing whatever they want abandoning
their children their women or whatever
else obviously
um but I think again this comes back to
what I said the Injustice on both sides
this is what yomukuyama is for can I you
know if there's an injustice committed
against me as a man
who's married or or legal is a real day
um
but the same thing applies to women so
whether shortly married or not you know
what I mean legally or whatever else
this is what yomokuyama is for and so
this this is why it's very important the
vetting process takes place on both
sides for both men and women you know um
because you don't want to marry people
that are gonna you know uh make your
life more difficult you know obviously
that's not the purpose of marriage so I
I don't it's just my opinion again we
could do this all day it's just my
opinion that you know legal marriage
doesn't you know it doesn't help in
assisting that you know that's not going
to force someone
you're trying to use a system to force
someone to do something that they don't
want to do anyway and sometimes they're
forced into doing stuff that there's no
Islamic foundation for you know but
there is a legal one but not an Islamic
one and so it's too dangerous in my in
my personal opinion um to actually put
in the hands of people because Allah if
Allah would have seen fit for us to have
that sort of power you know whether male
or female because they're I don't know I
don't know how much power you have in
the legal system as a man I don't want
to say you're powerless but maybe you
can actually execute something that
you're not supposed to and because
you're angry at your partner you decide
to do it you know and that's not you
know if that option was supposed to be
there then it would have been there you
know in a charity sense I I some so I
don't see what you're saying yeah and I
I appreciate that we can have a civil
you know discussion about this I feel
like there's a lot of people who are not
willing to but I I do it but so I I
don't understand the first point about
there's no shuttery kind of ruling
um because there there is subtle
accountability for the man even after he
divorces
um to either take care of the woman for
x amount of time or and and to always
take care of his kids so long as they
are you know a woman unmarried or like a
man under puberty and that stuff
um so like that does exist
pardon me
I'm talking from a western legal
understanding where you might pay like
uh what is it called alimony for like
the next 10 years or until she gets
married again you know what I mean this
type of thing is what I mean yeah yeah I
and I agree I agree that Western Law is
wrong but this is the point that Islam
did not come to be implemented in what
under Western Law it came to be the
state Islam came to be the whole state
so what we're doing is half applying
Islam because we are forced to have
apply Islam and I'm saying that that is
the main problem if we had Sharia it
would be perfect 100 we wouldn't have to
worry about this divorce settlements and
this no fault divorce all this garbage
right but living in this Western system
we do have to kind of evaluate both ends
and I I don't think it's a
one-size-fit-all I think it really does
depend on the situation if a man wants
to be poligenous it doesn't make sense
for him to uh get a legal marriage
because okay what about the other three
or maybe you'll do it once and not for
the other three it doesn't really make
sense to be honest but if a man doesn't
plan on on being positioned or if he
can't afford it which most men can't in
nowadays
um then I think it does make sense
especially if the woman
is like for for like let's say she
doesn't have family here she's the only
one here if she gets divorced she has
nowhere else to go she has to take care
of herself I think it's a very real
possibility and and solution for her to
uh to legally get married so she has
some form of protection and on top of
that the mannequin put a prenup the
woman can sign on her own accord that um
you know I'm not going to take half the
assets so I'll take x amount maybe maybe
we're talking past each other but what
does this protection look like let me
ask that question from your perspective
what does that protection what does that
mean
so I'm talking about financial
protection that's that's all that really
accommodates I think
um I think okay
islamically her protection is three
months right I mean this is what I would
my understanding yeah and then
pardon me
I said if if she's pastor itha
then what's her right beyond that do you
see do you see what I'm saying yeah yeah
yeah so islamically um if she needs help
the the state will help her in some
cases after the three months of the man
helping her he's still responsible for
taking care of his kids right like the
basic necessity economically yeah but in
the legal sense it falls upon not just
the the the man but the woman as well so
there's room to argue oh the man is he's
only reporting eighteen thousand dollars
a year so his child supports only two
three hundred dollars and a lot like
come on two three hundred dollars is
gonna get you some papers for school and
a few pencils nowadays yeah I like to
speak from this because you know I have
a I have a child in the United Kingdom
with an ex and I think this this comes
back to you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
talk in circles here I go back in
circles all the time this comes back to
bedding and married the woman she's very
religious woman
she's you know married again and we have
a child together she never went to the
legal system against me because you know
she felt that like this is not it's not
appropriate for Muslims and we've had a
very good agreement over this time
and things have been working you know
half decent half well you know uh when I
say I have decent half well there's been
no problems you know something a lot of
things taken care of for everybody so I
mean I think this is more of like you
know just pay attention to who you marry
uh more than anything else you know
because
there's signs that the guy's gonna be a
bum prior to prior to getting married
you know what I mean you could say the
same thing about women though can't you
say the same thing about women yeah no
absolutely and I'm a fan of Betty crazy
eyes got the crazy eyes
I think I tell guys all the time
whatever happens to you with your own
fault even if she doesn't because you
allow that woman into your life why did
you not pay closer attention you know to
who she was because you're marrying her
you're letting this person into your
life and when you let someone in your
life what does that do
it's like letting a businessman into
your into your business and he becomes a
partner he has the ability to
financially wreck you make sure you get
the right partner you know this is in
all Affairs so I'm 100 with you on that
you know you it's it's a two-way door
where the walis need to do better jobs
and and brothers need to do a better job
you know and turn off the I guess the
horny for lack of a better term you know
oh she said yes uh let's go you know
surprise six months later yeah protect
us um uh I I do I do I do agree 100 I
think that people should hold themselves
accountable not just kind of blame other
things or other factors and aspects
unless it's completely out of the
control I mean let's protect us and our
marriages I think there's a bigger issue
fundamentally which is that men and
women are just not ready for marriage or
not willing to actually be in a proper
marriage they just have this ideal
understanding what it is and and they're
not really looking at holding themselves
to a high standard as a spouse whether
it's husband or wife um I do have to get
going we have people coming very soon so
I don't have to run off up American I
think if you want to there are people in
the call room I think are my is here if
you want to stream the call-in aspect on
your channel I think that'll be sick
it's completely up to you inshaallah but
I do have to get going unfortunately
provide with them if they just want to
come in and divide until you know
someone acts crazy and then I'll Just
Bounce
all right I'll give it 10 minutes
inshallah before someone acts crazy but
um everyone else bought a club thank you
for joining me I love bless you all
amazing let's just I guess allow
everyone else in the waiting room the
two brothers in here and yeah I'm gonna
go crazy
um thank you for your time guys uh good
to talk to you uh Romy good to see you
again Abu American uh and thank you guys
again for indirectly giving me uh dawa
much appreciated
hopefully I'll talk to you soon
I mean I mean
all right
for joining us today I'm going to
discuss a lot of great stuff and uh
hopefully we'll do it again very soon
all right and um I guess because I'm
gonna end the stream I'll say this while
you're here
and inshallah we'll see you guys on the
next one
foreign